hey everybody hopefully watch the trail
a billion times but a bunch of you have
been messaging me about Ned Stark and a
couple other really specific things so I
wanted to make a video for the Easter
eggs there's a new round of the giveaway
for the HBO now subscription all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so there
were a number of things in conjunction
with the behind-the-scenes videos that
revealed some more details that were in
the trailer just buried very deeply a
lot of them involving things that either
reference or directly show Ned Stark so
Ned Stark is ever-present in the series
even though he's been dead for a long
time but the first one is a very literal
flashback to something that happened in
the past some of you saw this scene here
and wondered if this might be young Ned
Stark going to see Jaime Lannister
standing over the body of the Mad King
like oh are we actually going to
flashback to the end of Robert's
rebellion the timeline for the rebellion
is that we've gotten the tower of joy
that happened after the moment where Ned
Stark found Jaime Lannister over the mad
Kings body he had killed him just as
their forces were outside of the city
getting ready to ram down the gate the
Mad King was getting ready to light the
entire city on wildfire and as Jamie is
told that he was left alone with the Mad
King and came to the conclusion that he
was better off dead it was justice the
Ned Stark hairdo is very clear these are
the gold cloaks it's very clearly Jaime
Lannister in the background but it turns
out this is just a ryu shot of a scene
from season 1 episode 3 where Ned Stark
is going to see Robert Baratheon and he
passes by Jaime sitting over the Iron
Throne and they discuss him killing the
Mad King Jaime references the death of
Ned's brother Brandon and his father
Rickard stark at the hand of the macking
500 people sat here in silence and
watched them scream till they died I'm
stunning I can't when data is very brave
and your father too I didn't deserve to
die like that
nobody deserves to die like that you
just stood there marched 500 men just
took that lot so it's an amazing scene
and we could flashback to that but the
behind the scenes video is just reusing
that shot so you can take from that what
you will I do think that we'll continue
to see Robert's rebellion flashbacks
because they said the biggest reason
they weren't going to do that as a
prequel was because they were going to
cover it all during the main series and
there's still a lot of things we haven't
seen yet like the tourney at Harrenhal
second big detail Jaime Lannister on the
field of fire here trying to charge down
a dragon which it actually looks like is
really Viserion instead of drogon riding
ahead of the blood riders I know there
are a lot of theories about Daenerys
losing one of her dragons I definitely
think the drogon is safe so if we're
going to see one die it'll be Viserion
or ragel and I do not think that this is
how Jaime Lannister is going to die
trying to ride down a dragon I think the
implication is that this is going to be
a big moment for him so even if they
lose Casterly Rock
it'll still be a big personal win for
him I mean charging down a dragon is a
ballsy move normally if it were anyone
else I would say they would be instantly
barbecued but because it's Jaime
Lannister and there are seven episodes I
think we'll at least see him outlive
Cersei you've asked me for a death
predictions video - I do think most of
the main cast will be slowly peeled off
over the course of the six episodes of
season eight so each one of those
episodes will probably see a really big
death there are only a couple people I
think that are going to die this season
Littlefinger being at the top of my list
speaking of which next big detail
santa's quote when the snows fall and
the white winds blow the lone wolf dies
but the pack survives so there are a lot
of theories about who she's talking
about and who she's talking to when
she's saying that because it's just
voiceover so it's completely out of
context the reality is it's meant to be
ambiguous the way they use it in the
trailer is meant to apply to everyone
the lone wolf in the context of Daenerys
Cersei the Starks we need to band
together in order to survive but it also
applies to the other characters like
Arya Stark Jon Snow Sansa Stark so if
you've been rewatching the series
recently or
you've been rereading the books you
probably remember that quote is a Ned
Stark quote that aria herself references
twice the first time that we hear the
quote was actually during this scene
right here he doesn't say it on the TV
show but in the book version of this
scene he says it to her he's basically
telling her that she needs to stick with
her sister Sansa because at this point
in the story they still hated each other
she didn't want to have anything to do
with her sonses really excited about the
attorney that's going to be happening
really soon Aria doesn't give a [ __ ] so
Ned Stark tells her that we've come to a
dangerous place we need to stick
together we're family the second time
the quote appears is when Aria is
remembering the scene later during feast
for crows she's been on her own for a
while
and she says to herself the old gods are
dead with mother and father and Rob and
brand and Rickon all dead a long time
ago she remembered her father saying
that when the cold winds blow the lone
wolf dies in the pack survives she
thinks to herself he had it all
backwards aria
the lone wolf still lived but the Wolves
of the pack had been taken and slain and
skin bit of a twist on that idea but
it's a recurring theme it's sort of the
theme of how stark in addition to winter
is coming so very stark heavy season
winter has come so the lone wolf dies
but the pack survives so I think the
trailer has been very misleading about
what thoughts those feelings are about
Jon Snow the rest of her family I think
the big twist is it Littlefinger will
wind up being the lone wolf and he will
wind up dying Sansa will think of her
family she will be part of the pack and
then there's a lot of speculation about
how Littlefinger might die how Sansa
might get rid of him how Arya might be
the person to do it in that's how she
gets his cat's paw Valyrian dagger
so just remember the Littlefinger would
not give his dagger away and she's
wearing it in all these season 7 promos
Arya will get a Valyrian dagger whether
or not she gives that to Jon because it
does look like he has needle or the
Valyrian dagger on him here so there's
still a lot of speculation to be had but
it just sounds like Sansa will come to
her senses it won't be the crazy drama
that people think that it might end up
being in speaking of family drama I know
a lot of people are wondering if this
might be the Hound
the place where they filmed all the
dragon pit scenes in King's Landing so
that would mean that he'd have to be in
King's Landing near the mountain that
could lead to Clegane ville but on
closer inspection this looks more like
bran just because of the way he wears
his costume the way he knots his belt is
exactly like bran he wears lighter
colored pants like bran in virtually
every preview we've seen of the Hound or
of him with snow blowing across his face
in the far north so he would have to
travel a long way to get down to King's
Landing so I don't want to - anyone
clicking bow hopes but I just think that
this looks more like bran but you guys
can let me know in the comments next big
small detail is just bran and Meera
going underneath the wall we knew that
they would make it south eventually
because bran is in Winterfell in the
chair and this shot so he had to get
there at some point but you can see them
very tiny here just slowly passing
beneath the gate this is probably going
to be episode 1 episode 2 and after
re-watching the trailer like seven or
eight more times I now do think that
this person turned around standing next
to John on the rock here with Varrick is
the Hound himself just because he's
wearing a slightly different clothing
the only other really big things I saw
that not a lot of people were talking
about was euron greyjoy this is
confirmed to be euron greyjoy
but because the peasants and Kings
Landing are cheering and these are his
ships
it sounds like coupled with the
behind-the-scenes photo he's bringing
captives in and I don't want to say who
the captive is but if you saw my
behind-the-scenes video I talked a
little about that it sounds like he
brings someone that the Lannisters
desperately want revenge against and
they'll be really happy and that'll be
the tipping point for the alliance
between Euron and Cersei but I'm sure
there's a billion other things in this
trailer that we haven't unpacked yet
there'll be more Game of Thrones later
this week I'll talk about Mira and her
Valyrian sword that she might have the
Bloodraven sword called dark sister and
it'll probably also be some more
behind-the-scenes footage hoping to see
some Samwell in the next trail if they
drop believe all your requests in the
comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Luke Pernell please private
message me so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
click here to rewatch the trailer again
and you can click here for all my other
season 7 videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight